[Music]
this week the government has been
celebrating its first bespoke
post-brexit trade deal
the arrangement of australia is seen as
a coup for global britain
but it wasn't long before detractors
criticized that it would put british
farming under unfair competition
so should brits be welcoming the deal
i'm joined now by tony abbott
advisor to the uk board of trade and the
former australian prime minister
as well as james forsyth the spectator's
political editor
tony you've been pushing for this deal
for over a year so
did you celebrate when the news came
through absolutely
like just about every other australian i
see this deal as restoring a
relationship that should never have been
broken back in the 1970s
when britain joined what was to become
the european union
britain and australia have always been
family
and always should be family and this
deal is a way of re-establishing
the kinds of family bonds that we always
had
and will now have again james from the
uk perspective
uh how big a deal is this because we've
heard a lot about how oh
well it actually won't have a huge
impact on the economy in terms of growth
but
is it more a political triumph i think
there are three big
implications of this deal the first is
if the uk couldn't have signed a free
trade deal for australia
a country which is also governed
english-speaking country governed by a
center-right government
it would have been very hard to see who
on earth the uk was going to sign a
trade deal with
i so that's the first significance the
second is i think this puts the uk
on course to join the comprehensive and
progressive trans-pacific
partnership big trading blocks centered
around
the pacific ocean with and i think the
particular significance of that is
if the wto uh becomes uh fundamentally
unworkable because of tensions between
china and the west
i think groups like cptp are going to be
what countries fall back on
and then i think the third significance
of it is
that i've always thought the domestic
politics of a u.s uk trade deal are very
difficult
but i think after the midterm elections
you might see the biden administration
look at taking the you
the us into cptp and so i think in a way
this perhaps
paves the way for that deal as well
tony when we're looking at the pros and
cons of this deal
one of the points of controversy here in
the uk and the build up uh has been on
agri food on australian farmers uh
there's been some kickback
uh in the end a deal has been agreed but
there is a 15-year wait
um at times were you worried the
protectionists might stop that
in the uk look uh
i was certainly a little dismayed at the
level of protectionism
in some corners of britain but
look every sectional interest is
effectively a vested interest and
vested interests will always put their
pitch but in the end i was confident
that the good sense of the british
people and the good sense of the boris
johnson
government would prevail the important
thing to remember
is that this deal is better for both
countries
from day one from day one
australian goods and australians will
have better access to britain
and british goods and britons will have
better access
to australia tony is there anything in
the deal that you think
australia would have been reluctant the
government to sign up to because because
there are various uh you know
commitments on climate change at the uk
side pushed for and appeared to be in it
katie look um obviously we have yet to
see
uh how the thing has elaborated in
writing
but my understanding is that the uk
government and the australian government
have agreed
uh that further commitments if any on
emissions reduction will be pursued as
part of the cop process
now as you know i'm not an emission
zealot
i would like to see emissions restrained
and if possible reduced but i certainly
don't want to see
economies turned upside down and
impoverished in order to do so
so i certainly think that there's a lot
of overblown rhetoric when it comes to
climate
that said i am a conservationist
i want to see the highest possible
environmental standards the highest
possible
animal welfare standards the highest
possible labor standards
and i think any britain that knows
australia would realize that we are all
conservationists that hardy
we certainly don't mistreat our animals
and
australian workers get a very a fair go
indeed
as indeed should be the case in britain
you see it should be very easy
to do a deal between two countries that
have such
comparable attitudes and such comparable
living standards
and that that's why it was very
important to get this deal done
and why it's very important that it was
such a
comprehensive and high quality deal so
um after waiting through a bit of
unnecessary rgb
behind closed doors that seems to be
where
thanks to the good work of dan t and the
australian minister and
liz trust the british minister and of
course our respective prime ministers
scott morrison and boris johnson that's
where we've got to
and james i suppose just quickly a final
question or two do you think that
climate change
could be a point of uh i suppose
conflict between the australian
government and the uk government because
we know the two sides have a lot in
common
and but boris johnson is pushing very
hard on his net zero on cop 26 we're
just in that g7
so is that going to be something to
watch out for
look i think if you want to phase out
coal australia is
is one of the countries you need to
persuade of
the merits of that uh i think that you
know this is going to be a major part of
uk diplomacy and i use you saw at the
the g7 summit in cornwall you know that
the importance
that boris johnson placed on and also
the fact that you know the uk's
integrated review describes this as one
of
uh one of if not the uk's foreign policy
priorities
i i think the interesting question is
you know to how much you to what extent
there are kind of coalitions of the
willing on this
uh and to what extent that you do
everything through
uh the the the um process
look if i could just katie if i could
just make a point here
um china is by far the world's biggest
emitter
uh china produces something like 30
percent of global emissions
china is not promising to reduce its
emissions
at all over the next decade it's
promised
to get to ned zero by 2060
10 years after britain and other
countries and to be honest
china's promises are not reliable
china's emissions have gone up by almost
a hundred percent
uh over the last 15 years china is
absolutely relentlessly dedicated to
making itself stronger
vis-a-vis the west and and we need to be
extremely
careful about doing things that are
going to make us weaker
vis-a-vis china and look we all want to
reduce emissions
but to be absolutely blunt with you
there are far more important
geopolitical questions
at issue today and the last thing that
any of us should be doing
is making ourselves economically weaker
because in the end military strength is
a function of economic strength is
making ourselves
economically weaker in ways which
are not going to materially impact
on climate because of the massive
increase in emissions out of china
james the uk government boris johnson
has been talking about china with scott
morrison on his visit here
so do you think that uh boris johnson um
his view reflects a little bit of what
tony's been saying or not when it comes
to that approach and that balancing act
i think there is a china aspect to this
trade deal if you look at ever since
australia called for an independent who
investigation into the origins of
coronavirus
china has been trying to use its
economic relationship with australia
to put pressure on canberra you know
you've had
tariffs slapped on australian goods
bureaucratic obstacles put in the face
of australian exports
i think if in those circumstances the uk
had not been able to negotiate a trade
deal with australia
and then i think it would have weakened
western solidarity against china
i also think there's been a very
important demonstration here because uh
new zealand has been very very cautious
about criticizing china it doesn't want
to go through what australia has gone
through indeed the new zealand has
suggested that the answer to the
australia china problem is for australia
to show more respect to beijing
and but i think there is a hope there is
i mean there's a reason to hope here
that if you can say to me look you have
got yourself into this position of
dependency on china which is frankly
unhealthy
there are alternative trading options
available i i think that would be a good
thing i think i think that you know
australia has woken up
to the dangers created by it by by the
fact that a
economic relationship with china china
will try and use that to
influence your foreign policy and i
think we have to hope that new zealand
will realize the dangers of this too
and just very briefly the other point
that needs to be made is that a lot of
countries are
are climate hypocrites frankly um
australia is often criticized
because we don't want to sign up
instantly
to some commitment 30 years hence
but if you actually look at what we have
achieved
our emissions are down almost 15 percent
since 2005 uh canada
which is a climate darling its emissions
are down
just one percent and new zealand which
likewise likes to parade its climate
virtue
its emissions are down only four percent
so
look at what countries do uh not
at what they promise to do and when it
comes to
actually getting things done australia
is pretty damn good
james do you think the uk government can
learn from australia on climate change
i think there is an interesting question
about i think ambitious targets do
serve a purpose uh in that uh
they they force politicians to confront
hard choices that they might
otherwise avoid but but i think that
your these obviously these targets
don't work if countries don't meet them
and and the other thing that has to be
considered is the cost of meeting these
targets now it's all very well for
politicians to say look in 30 years time
we'll do this
but they won't be held accountable for
the costs of actually meeting those
targets their successes
two or three generations political
generations later
we'll we'll have to do all of this and
while all of us want
uh to get emissions down as far and as
fast
as we can there is a very significant
cost to all of this
in terms of jobs in more traditional
industries
in terms of the extra cost of redundancy
to renewable power
and none of this can be discounted
tony and james thank you very much
[Music]
you